let's take a quick look at how to use  google cloud sequel on the command line  go to cloud google.com and open up the  cloud console go to the sequel section  here you can see your cloud sequel  instances if you don't have a cloud  sequel instance you can create one click  your instance to be taken to the  instance overview page now go to the  access control tab and then go to the  users tab specify a new root password if  you don't have the Google Cloud SDK  installed on your computer see the link  in the description for how to install it  now open your command line and type G  cloud beta sequel connect the name of  your instance and then the username root  type in your password and you'll be  greeted with the familiar my sequel  command line